Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, was passiert eigentlich, wenn man alle Fake News Server auf der Welt abschaltet?
Dann gibt es keine Wahrheiten mehr.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 525 vom 7. Juni 2025.
Ganz viel 25 hier am Start.
Ja, wir waren kurz weg, jetzt mal wieder da, weil wir müssen uns ja um die Wahrheit kümmern.
Wir müssen die Wahrheit retten.
Weil es gibt jetzt einen Mangel oder es gab einen Mangel an Wahrheit.
Kurzzeitigen Mangel an Wahrheiten im Internet. Da springen wir natürlich ein
und helfen gerne sofort.
Ich bin gerade nochmal davon gekommen, würde ich sagen.
Ja, weil sich Elon Musk und Donald Trump jetzt streiten wie die Katzen oder die Hunde.
Ey, das ist so, es ist so würdelos.
Es ist würdeloser, als ich es mir vorgestellt habe. nein, es ist genauso würdelos,
wie ich es mir übertrieben vorgestellt habe.
Und es war halt klar, dass die sich irgendwann im Streit auseinander gehen würden.
Man hat sich so die Augen gerieben, wie der Trump den einfach verabschiedet
hat und du dachtest so, krass, die haben sich echt am Riemen gerissen.
Da hätte man denen gar nicht zugetraut.
Hat nicht lange gehalten.
Oh Mann, ey.
Ja, wer das amerikanische Geschehen nicht verfolgt, erstmal Gratulation.
Ich dachte ja am Anfang dieser zweiten Trump-Ära, das blende ich jetzt vier
Jahre aus, ich halte mir einfach die Ohren zu hoch und sage na na na na na, aber ging leider nicht.
Gut, ihr werdet es im Wesentlichen dann doch wahrscheinlich auch mitbekommen
haben aber jetzt greifen die da rum und,
also wie.
War das denn der Trump hat der Musk hat getwittert dass er das,
Big Beautiful Bill Neue Gesetzesinitiative.
Mit der sozusagen die Republikaner den Staat jetzt komplett ausrauben.
Ja, und da hat er unter anderem kommt da glaube ich drin vor,
dass die Subsidies für Elektroautos wegfallen oder so oder ich weiß nicht genau was, aber irgendwas.
Ja, ist so.
Und Musk meinte, das findet er nicht gut.
Ja, er meinte gut, er hat generell gesagt.
Dass das Ding eine Genau.
Es wäre eine Abomination, was es ja auch ist, weil es natürlich die Verschuldung
der USA nochmal ins Wahnsinnige treibt.
Es ist immer dasselbe Spiel. Immer wenn die Demokraten am Start sind,
dann müssen sie erstmal den Staatshaushalt sanieren.
Das gelingt ihnen dann auch. und dann werden wieder die Republikaner gewählt,
weil es ja eigentlich alles in Ordnung, aber man hat ihnen irgendwie gesagt,
dass es nicht alles in Ordnung ist und dann kommen die Republikaner und müssen
wieder die Steuern senken, für wen?
Natürlich für die Reichen, damit die noch mehr Geld verdienen und normalerweise
müssen dann halt auch die Sozialausgaben gekürzt werden, weil man hat ja kein
Geld mehr, weil das muss man ja den Reichen geben.
Jetzt wollen sie aber irgendwie zumindest noch ein bisschen sozial sein und
deswegen wird das alles jetzt sehr teuer.
Also wird die Staatsverschuldung nochmal enorm angehoben, weil wir sind ja die
Weltwährung, wir können das ja machen.
Sie alles tun, dass ihre Währung nicht mehr die Weltwährung ist.
Also das ist,
Lange wird das auf jeden Fall nicht mehr gut gehen.
Nein, das wird nicht mehr lange gut gehen.
Genau.
Dann sagt Musk, er findet das nicht gut. Da hat der Trump sich noch am Schniebel
gerissen und konnte da drüber stehen.
Und dann hat Musk aber gesagt, ja, ich habe aber hier so und so viele Millionen
in diesem Wahlkampf und wenn ich den Wahlkampf nicht gekauft hätte,
dann wäre der Trump nicht Präsident geworden.
So eine, so undankbar.
Und dann? Besser kann man einfach offene Korruption gar nicht besser dokumentieren. Okay.
So undankbar. Ja, und dann? Und dann haben die sich irgendwie...
Angefangen zu zanken, dann sagte der Trump irgendwie,
ich weiß gar nicht genau, was Trump als erstes dann über seinen Truth.Social
verbreitet hat, aber ich glaube, so die Grenze war überschritten,
als dann Elon Musk meinte,
jetzt muss ich mal hier eine richtig große Bombe droppen, der Donald Trump ist in den Epstein-Files.
Wir erinnern uns Jeffrey Epstein, irgendwie Milliardär,
der, also ich hoffe, dass ich das jetzt richtig zusammenfasse,
aber der irgendwie Partys gemacht hat mit viel zu jungen Frauen die ganze Zeit
und tatsächlich eine Reihe von sehr einflussreichen Menschen um sich geschart hat,
unter anderem diesem Prinz Andrew.
Und viele andere Leute und ich habe da vor Jahren irgendwie eine Doku drüber
gesehen und der dann irgendwie, obwohl man damit rechnen musste,
dass er sich suizidiert, das dann auch geschafft hat und damit war dieser,
Fall irgendwie mehr oder weniger versunken.
Dann gab es noch die Giselle Maxwell oder wie die heißt, seine Partnerin und offensichtlich mit.
Gis Lane oder Ghislaine?
Ghislaine.
Und also ganz, also wirklich auch, das ist eine krasse, da kannst du mal eine
Verschwörungstheorie draus machen, mit wem der alles rumgehangen hat.
Und jetzt, und es gibt, aber auch schon war auch bekannt, dass es Bilder gibt
von Musk mit Epstein vor irgendwie 30 Jahren oder so.
Auch irgendwie von CNN gefilmt im Kreise von damals schon viel zu jungen Frauen,
die irgendwie um die da rumtanzen wie auch immer. Ähm...
Und dann sagt Trump, ja, ich könnte jetzt Geld sparen, indem ich einfach mal
die ganzen Verträge von Elon Musk mit der Regierung kündige und die Subsidies,
also die Subventionen auf seine Elektroautos und so.
Ich habe mich eh schon gewundert, dass der Biden das nicht gemacht hat.
Und dann sagt er noch irgendwas zu seinem Drogenkonsum.
Dann sagt Steve Bannon, ja okay, der Musk soll einfach deportiert werden.
Weil er ja ein illegaler Migrant ist, der bestimmt nicht alles richtig ausgefüllt hat damals.
Ja, es gibt irgendein Video, wo Musk und sein Bruder irgendwie darüber scherzen,
dass sie vielleicht bei der Migration irgendwie tatsächlich einiges...
Und dann sagt Musk wieder irgendwie, ja, der hat die ganze Zeit Drogen genommen
und seine scheiß Elektroautos, die will eh keiner haben.
Und dann wollte er noch die Dragon, dann hat er gesagt, okay,
ihr wollt uns die Subventionen streichen, dann streichen wir einfach das Dragon-Kapsel-Programm.
Sozusagen der ist halt der einzige Weg, um Astronauten auf die ISS zu bringen.
Nö, du kannst doch mit der Sojus-Kapsel fliegen.
Nee.
Geht nicht?
Russland irgendwie.
Das ist doch für Trump kein Problem.
Naja, aber es ist halt, wie soll ich sagen, die haben die Dragon-Kapsel jetzt
gefeiert, nachdem Amerika irgendwie 15, 20 Jahre lang nicht mehr in der Lage
war, Astronauten ins All zu schicken, sondern immer auf die Russen angewiesen waren. Ja.
Und derzeit, ja, also, es ging einfach die ganze Zeit hin und her Und jetzt
haben sie sich erstmal wieder ein bisschen eingekriegt und dann mittendrin kam
dann irgendwie auch noch dieser bekloppte Rapper.
Hast du noch?
50 Cent.
Nee, der ist nicht bekloppt. 50 Cent hast du, glaube ich, noch alle beisammen. Kanye West.
Kanye West?
Kanye West, der sich, glaube ich, auch wieder irgendeinen komischen Namen gegeben
hat. Interessiert mich auch nicht.
Der dann so, ja, aber streitet euch doch nicht. Ich habe euch doch beide so lieb.
Es gab auch irgendeinen Rapper, der da auch noch... Ach, herrje.
Es ist so erbärmlich. Auf jeden Fall haben Zelensky und Putin dann angeboten,
zwischen den beiden zu vermitteln.
Ach nee, das war so eine Internet-Wahrheit. War Frustellion.
Ja, aber ich meine, es ist wirklich interessant, weil Musk hat ja nun,
auch wenn man sich darüber den Kopf hält, auch so seine Fans und seine Follower
und so weiter, die ihm ja irgendwie auch alles glauben.
Und diese ganze Mager-Crowd hat sich nun irgendwie auch so auf die beiden eingeritten,
dass sie sich jetzt so ein bisschen zwischen Mama und Papa entscheiden müssen,
und es ist noch nicht so richtig absehbar, wohin das führt.
Ich meine, du hast es schon gesagt, es sind alles Chancen, dass Elon Musk nochmal Millionär wird.
Ja, also ich glaube, da sind wir noch nicht so ganz, aber das nimmt kein gutes Ende für ihn.
Also ich sehe einfach nicht meine... Gut, SpaceX ist.
Das ist zumindest noch irgendwie so ein Unternehmen, was so eine Berechtigung,
hat in ihrem Dasein. Weil das einfach nur,
gut, abgesehen jetzt von den letzten und Tests, aber Test und Tests und so weiter
und Space ist hart, aber ich meine, die haben im Alleingang innerhalb von zehn
Jahren von, wir wissen nicht, ob unsere Rakete fliegt zu, wir übernehmen jetzt mal hier den Weltmarkt,
da eine Performance hingelegt, die schon wirklich bemerkenswert ist und nicht
ohne Grund weist Elon Musk quasi da so links mal eben drauf hin,
dass die USA eigentlich extrem von ihm abhängt.
Wie jedes andere Land auch.
Also sagen wir mal so, wenn die Kapitalisten und die Autokraten sich streiten, freut sich der Dritte.
Und ich glaube, es wäre, also ich finde es auf jeden Fall ganz okay, dass,
diese Freundschaft ein Ende findet. Weil der reichste Mann der Welt mit dem
mächtigsten Mann der Welt,
das war eh schwierig. Also alles, was du machst.
Wie endet das? Endet das italienisch oder endet es russisch?
Oh, meinst du, Der Musk fliegt aus dem Fenster.
Interessant. Das glaube ich halt auch nicht. Glaube ich auch nicht, nee.
Aber ich weiß nicht, also das kann ja gar kein gutes Ende nehmen mit ihm.
Mit dem Musk? Nee. Aber das ist ja auch schon länger klar, dass das kein gutes Ende nimmt.
Naja gut, also das ist auch am Ende nicht unser Problem. Es ist halt jetzt so
interessant, was das mit dieser ganzen Marga-Republik anstellt.
Im Zweifelsfall sind sie natürlich alle noch irgendwie Trump,
aber die verbrennen halt ihre Helden mit einer Geschwindigkeit derzeit.
Da muss man mal gucken, ob zu den Midterm-Wahlen da noch viel von übrig bleibt.
Also mit ein bisschen Glück übertreiben sie es auch wirklich so dermaßen,
dass sie wirklich überall den Halt verliert.
Aber das haben wir schon natürlich oft gehofft und sind oft enttäuscht worden.
Also weißt du, was ich so schwierig finde, Tim? Das ist ja völlig in Ordnung,
wenn die sich zanken und so. Und wenn die da Meinungsverschiehen haben.
Aber das Niveau, also.
Das ist so erbärmlich.
Das ist so, also so überhaupt so peinlich.
Und ich, also, das macht mich ganz wuschig.
Ich kann das gar nicht gut finden. Ich kann das gar nicht genießen,
weil das so würdelos ist.
Naja, ich weiß nicht, in gewisser Hinsicht, wenn der Streit jetzt auch noch
mit Würde ausgetragen werde, das würde mich mehr bestören.
Also insofern finde ich das eigentlich
schöner, dass es dann auch so eine richtige Schlammschlacht wird.
Das ist richtig, aber weißt du, was meine Sorge ist?
Ernsthaft, dass die Leute sich das angucken und denken, naja.
Wenn der Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten und einer, der mal der reichste Mann der Welt war,
sich so aufführen können oder das tun,
Dann kann ich mich ja auch völlig beknackt die ganze Zeit verhalten und habe
dafür eine Rechtfertigung.
Und ein Teil des Lebens ist eben auch, sich ein bisschen, ein kleines bisschen ziviler zu verhalten.
Und auch eine gewisse Würde in der Auseinandersetzung zu wahren.
Dass man beispielsweise versucht, über irgendwelche moralischen Aspekte zu kommen oder so.
Dass man irgendwie versucht, Nebenkriegsschauplätze oder irgendwie bösartige
Unterstellungen oder irgendwie so seinen Hass zu kanalisieren,
ja, aber nicht so ganz offen drohen, ja, also ich meine,
wenn du auf dem Niveau bist, dass du auf deinem Social, hast du nicht gesehen,
irgendwie jemand, ich mach deine Regierungsverträge weg und außerdem nimmst
du Drogen und damit, also,
Also weißt du, was ich meine?
Ich verstehe deinen Schmerz vollständig.
Da zanken sich irgendwie die Hamas mit der israelischen Regierung würdevoller.
Inhaltlich, sorry, also inhaltlich. Die führen Argumente an,
die sich wenigstens noch auf...
Auf irgendwelche Werte oder auf irgendwelche höheren Ideen beziehen.
Bitte wirklich jetzt vorsichtig.
Jetzt hast du wieder das.
Nein, aber die argumentieren über historische Themen, die führen irgendwas an.
Die bringen Themen an und nicht einfach nur du bist undankbar aber ich mach
dir die Verträge, ich verkaufe meinen Tesla. Also das ist, verstehst du, was ich meine?
Ja, ich verstehe voll, was du meinst.
Ich meine, aber das ist ja nun mit Trump ohnehin schon komplett abhandengekommen.
Das war ja nun auch in der ersten Amtszeit nicht sehr viel besser.
Und wir werden ja auch später schon nochmal diskutieren, wie so Teile davon
auch zu uns rüber schwappen.
Ich kann immer nur hoffen, dass meine Theorie der ewigen Sinuswelle irgendwie hält.
Man kann ja auf zwei Arten und Weisen auf die Welt schauen, nämlich es wird immer alles schlimmer.
Ja.
Oder es wird es wird zwar vieles immer schlimmer aber andere Dinge werden gleichzeitig
auch besser und die Dinger, die irgendwie total schlimm sind die es irgendwie
vollkommen übertreiben werden dann auch schnell wieder abstürzen also Tim.
Ich sag dir ja eins wenn du wenn du noch irgendwelche goldenen 20er willst,
ich wüsste, dass das jetzt kommt dann brauchst du kein Sinus,
dann brauchst du ein Tangens,
dann brauchst du einen Tangens,
oder also es gibt ja Sinus, Cosinus und Tangens und der geht halt sehr sehr schnell dann hoch.
Ja also ich meine.
Mit zunehmend glaube ich unendlicher erste Ableitung ja.
Irgendwas Exponentiales ist sicherlich ganz angemessen, aber das ist ja auch nicht ausgeschlossen.
Ich meine, man hat nur Reaktionen, haben auch Gegenreaktionen und ich bin nicht
davon überzeugt, dass auf schlechte Trends in der Gesellschaft automatisch immer
nur noch schlechtere Trends der Gesellschaft kommen.
Ich korrigiere mich, ich habe mir die Grafik kurz malen lassen,
du brauchst eigentlich Co-Tangens.
Das wird jetzt immer schlimmer, dann kommt ganz kurz nichts und dann ist es
unendlich gut. Also wir brauchen Co-Tangens.
Mhm.
Damit es weniger schlecht wird.
Na, wenn du sagst, ein ewiger Sinus und es soll nochmal goldene 20er geben.
Ein Sinus ist ja gleichförmig, ne?
Ja.
Und wenn du dir jetzt Co-Tangents anguckst, dann wird es jetzt also das könnte
erklären, warum es gerade so ganz schnell dramatisch schlimmer wird.
Während eine Sinuskurve, dann wird es jetzt irgendwann langsam schlimmer,
langsam weniger schlimmer.
Du weißt, dass bei uns jetzt schon 30 Kommentare zum Beispiel Mathematik.
Ich will die ja.
Geometrisch. Gesamtwissen. Oh Mann, oh Mann, oh Mann.
Also auf einer Sinuswelle kommen wir nicht mehr in die goldenen Zwanziger. Das sag ich dir.
Naja. Da bin ich nicht so von überzeugt.
Auf jeden Fall ich muss sagen, es hat schon Popcorn-Qualitäten und das darf
man jetzt auch nicht vernachlässigen.
Lass sie sich doch gegenseitig zerfleischen. Triff die richtig.
Ich mache mir nur Sorgen um die Kinder.
Und um Elon Musk oder was?
Alle 300?
Das mit dem lächerlichen Namen.
Um das verstoßene Kind muss man sich keine Sorgen machen. Stabile Verhältnisse.
Aber alles andere ist dann...
Okay.
Alright, let's move on. Es gibt noch andere Sachen, wo wir uns aufregen können.
Feedback haben wir natürlich auch noch bekommen. Das wird jetzt hier natürlich,
erwähnt. Los geht's hier mit dem Papst.
Na, auch schon wieder der.
Ja. Unkatholisch interessiert kommentiert.
Am ersten Abend des Konklaves wird nur einmal gewählt.
Bei diesem ersten Durchgang geht es, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe,
auch nur sehr bedingt darum, tatsächlich einen Papst zu wählen.
Hier wird häufig Leuten eine Stimme gegeben, um ihnen den eigenen Respekt zu bezeugen.
Ach, so ist das, dass man deswegen, man fragt sich ja, warum die nicht in einem
Durchlauf den Vertreter Gottes auf Erden erkennen.
Weil ja immer Gott zu ihnen spricht. in der Situation. Das ist quasi in dem
Moment, sag Gott, sag denen mal, gib denen mal Respekt. Okay, verstehe. Ja.
So läuft das. Also häufig wird Leuten eine Stimme gegeben, um ihnen den eigenen Respekt zu bezeugen.
Das kann dazu führen, dass im ersten Wahlgang auch Leute gewählt werden,
die definitiv keine Aussicht auf eine erfolgreiche Wahl haben,
weil sie zum Beispiel zu alt sind.
Nach diesem ersten eher formalen Wahlgang gibt es schwarzen Rauch.
Ab dem zweiten Tag finden vormittags und nachmittags immer zwei Wahlgänge statt.
Das finde ich anders als ihr auch total sinnvoll.
Zeichnet sich etwa nach dem ersten Wahlgang der beiden Wahlgänge ab,
dass einem Kandidaten nur ganz wenige Stimmen fehlen, bekommen die Kardinale
gleich die Chance, denjenigen vielleicht doch direkt zu wählen.
Wozu sollen die nochmal den ganzen Tag diskutieren und beten,
wenn doch eigentlich eh klar ist, wer es wird.
Andersrum wäre es auch Quatsch, dann schwarzen Rauch aufsteigen zu lassen,
nur damit es eine Stunde später wieder den Papst gibt.
Am Vormittag gab es also schwarzen Rauch für die Wahlgänge 2 und 3.
Da der Rauch am sehr frühen Abend weiß war, konnte man ableiten,
dass die Wahl im ersten der beiden Wahlgänge des Nachmittags erfolgt war.
Ansonsten hätte das Ganze länger gedauert.
Die Staatsform im Vatikan finde ich auch ziemlich spannend. Das ist ja eine Wahlmonarchie.
Der auf Lebenszeit, der nannte Monarch, bezieht seine Legitimation sehr wohl
aus einem demokratischen Prozess, wenngleich die Zahl der Wahlberechtigten recht überschaubar ist.
Und die wohnen auch nicht in dem Staat, oder? Die sind ja woanders dann.
Was allerdings auf die Einwohner der Vatikanstadt auch zutreffen dürfte.
Und die katholische Kirche mit dem Selbstverständnis des Papst als Stellvertreter
Gottes auf Erden natürlich in der Außendarstellung dem Herren da eine gewisse
Einflussnahme unterstellen muss. Ja.
Interessante, ist richtig interessante Staatsform. Vielleicht können wir auch einfach mal,
wie viele Kardinäle gibt es, ein paar Leute hin, ein paar Leute aus aller Herren
Länder und wählen wählen einfach einen. Und dann fliegen die wieder nach Hause.
Weil die nicht bleiben dürfen.
Warum nicht mal in Parks?
Wegen Migration.
Weiteres Feedback gibt es zu der Geschichte um OpenAI. Da gibt es auch noch
ein paar Nachinformationen. Johannes S.
Schreibt bezüglich der Frage, ob OpenAI die Konversationen speichert,
muss man ganz klar, also Der Fall war ja, Gericht hat beschlossen,
OpenAI könnte unter Umständen vielleicht Copyright verletzt haben und deswegen,
damit man das nachweisen kann, dürfen sie ihre Logs nicht mehr löschen oder ihre, also Logs ist...
Eine Variante könnte man sagen, also einfach die eigentlichen Anfragen,
die Prompts, also das, was tatsächlich geschrieben wurde.
So und dazu schreibt Johannes, bezüglich der Frage, ob OpenAI die Konversation
speichert, muss man ganz klar zwischen OpenAI und ChatGPT unterscheiden.
OpenAI als LLM-Betreiber speichert meines Wissens keinen Inhalt der Konversation.
Praktisch gibt es in deren API-Architektur auch keine persistenten Konversationen.
Auf der anderen Seite gibt es ChatGPT, ein Produkt für Endkunden auf Basis dieser LLMs.
ChatGPT speichert natürlich deutlich mehr.
Ja, teilweise. Also die FAQ von OpenAI klärt zu diesem Fall nochmal explizit auf.
Und dieses Gerichtsurteil oder diese Gerichtsverfügung betrifft tatsächlich
jetzt die ChatGBT Free Plus Pro also diese typischen Chat-GPT-Abos,
die man da abschließen kann,
einschließlich der Team-Subscription.
Oder wenn man die OpenAI-API benutzt,
mit der Ausnahme eines sogenannten Zero-Data-Retention-Agreements,
also das ist sozusagen ein Vertrag, der das wohl explizit vorsieht.
Außerdem sind Chat-GPT-Enterprise und EduCustomers auch ausgenommen von dieser Verfügung. ähm,
Ja, und das ist sozusagen derzeit der Stand der Dinge.
Mittlerweile ist dann auch bekannt geworden, OpenAI geht also jetzt stark gegen
diese Verfügung vor und hat da so ein Code-Filing gemacht und meint,
es wäre ja alles hier total übertrieben, was die New York Times dort präsentiert
hätte und es gibt da überhaupt gar keine Anhaltspunkte und damit sollen sie doch erstmal kommen.
Und das hatten wir ja auch schon angesprochen und das wird auch von OpenAI auch
nochmal gesagt, dass sie halt einfach gerade sich gar nicht so sicher sind jetzt,
weil sie auf der einen Seite diesem Gerichtsurteil folgen müssen,
andererseits müssen sie aber natürlich auch in der EU compliant sein und dürfen
das sozusagen gar nicht, also
das Gericht in den USA hat jetzt etwas angeordnet, was quasi gegen die,
GDPR, also.
Datenschutzgrundverordnung verstößt. Und das ist natürlich für alle Beteiligten,
eine schwierige Situation.
Also muss man jetzt mal gucken, wie das ausgeht. Da geht es jetzt auf jeden Fall hin und her.
Wir haben da noch ein paar Links zu dem Fall noch dabei.
Dann gibt es noch Feedback zum Co-Pilot. Kurze Anmerkung zu Maybe Buggy schreibt.
Kurze Anmerkung zu GitHub Co-Pilot, da Tim meinte Claude sei dem voraus.
GitHub Co-Pilot hat keine eigenen Models, sondern nutzt nur vorhandene.
Zur Auswahl stehen bei mir aktuell Sonnet, Gemini und diese O-Modelle von OpenAI.
Ja, ist korrekt. Ich hatte das sozusagen ein bisschen impliziert.
Also Co-Pilot ist der AI Assistant des Frontend von Google, aber das impliziert
nicht automatisch ein Modell.
Das ist halt dieses Gemini.
Moment, Copilot ist von Microsoft.
Was habe ich gesagt?
Du hast gerade gesagt, Copilot wäre von Google. Gemini ist Google.
Copilot ist immer, wenn Microsoft irgendwas hergemacht.
Copilot ist von Microsoft, also was bei GitHub, also Microsoft hat ja GitHub
gekauft und der GitHub Copilot, da hat es gestartet, mittlerweile ist aber Copilot,
glaube ich, generell von Microsoft ihr Brand, mit dem sie,
das machen und das Gemini-Modell ist dann halt auch nur eins von mehreren,
was dort zur Verfügung kommt und da es beim Programmieren sagen wir mal noch
ein ziemlicher offener Wettbewerb ist,
wo tatsächlich dieses Sonnet-Modell von Claude, also von ganz Ropic auch ziemlich
weit vorne ist, ist das halt noch sehr offen, aber man hat viele Assistentensysteme,
die alle möglichen Modelle anbieten, weil das da ein offener Markt ist in gewisser Hinsicht.
Und dann wurde uns noch kurz ein TV-Tipp gegeben.
Und zwar hatten wir hier den Fall behandelt vor einiger Zeit von diesem Mr.
Bates, der einen Postshop im Prinzip hatte.
Dann war die Abrechnungssoftware buggy und die haben da irgendwie aber das nicht
anerkannt und haben diese Leute halt in den Ruin getrieben. wir hatten das hier
behandelt, da gibt es jetzt eine mehrteilige Serie drüber, Mr.
Bates gegen die Post und die kommt auch bei Arte ist sie gerade in der Mediathek,
kann man sich anschauen ich glaube wir hatten die Existenz der Serie erwähnt
aber nicht, dass sie gerade in der Arte Mediathek ist.
Linken wir in den Show Notes Also diese Serie war das glaube ich die das,
ich meine das ist die Serie, vielleicht gab es auch eine Dokumentation nochmal
separat aber auf jeden Fall durch die Berichterstattung übers Fernsehen kam
diese ganze Story dann überhaupt erst zu dieser Skandaldimension.
Das ist sicherlich ganz interessant.
Gut, kommen wir zur Innenpolitik und all dem.
Genau, wir haben ja einen neuen Kulturstaatsminister.
Das ist der Wolfram Weimar. Ich muss sagen, ich weiß, das ist der,
wo am Anfang sehr viel Kritik war,
dass man ihn über die Kultur entscheiden lassen würde.
Er hat einen relativ starken konservativen Hintergrund und konservativer Verleger
und das war irgendwie relativ klar,
dass man von dem jetzt eher nicht so eine starke kulturelle Vielfalt erwarten würde.
Ehrlich gesagt habe ich das nicht so genau verfolgt, aber es war auf jeden Fall
keine Besetzung, die die Leute gefeiert haben.
Was ich spannend finde in dem Kontext, er war Verleger und jetzt sagt er,
das war jetzt eine seiner ersten Ankündigungen,
das fand ich erstmal spannend von der Überschrift her,
er plant eine Digitalabgabe, die große Internetkonzerne wie Google und Meta zahlen sollen.
Er bereitet jetzt eine Gesetzesvorlage vor.
Und das hat er dem Stern erzählt. Und da sagt er, es geht nicht nur um Google
Ads, es geht generell um die Plattformbetreiber mit den Milliardenumsätzen.
Und wir halten einen Abgabesatz von 10% für moderat und legitim.
Das klingt jetzt erst mal nicht uninteressant, dass man sagt,
okay, wir wollen in diesem Land eine Kultur haben und aus diesen Gründen besteuern
wir jetzt diese Milliardenkonzerne.
Zu diesem spezifischen Zweck. Da wird in dem Artikel noch erwähnt,
in Österreich gibt es das schon.
Das sind große Online-Plattformen seit 2020, verpflichtet 5% der Einkünfte aus der Werbevermarktung.
Müssen sie irgendwie abführen.
Und dann gibt es aber noch dieses wunderschöne, klitzekleine Zitat.
Die Erlöse sollen dem Medienstandort zugutekommen.
Und ich finde es natürlich, wenn ein ehemaliger Verleger über den Medienstandort
redet, dann kann ich mir schon vorstellen, in welche Richtung er sich da entwickelt
in welche Richtung das weitergehen wird mit seinen Überlegungen,
wie denn der Kultur- und Medienstandort in Deutschland gesichert werden soll
und wohin dieses Geld gehen soll ich bin mal gespannt in den Artikeln,
die es da bisher gibt steht da noch nicht mehr drüber das liegt dann sehr,
daran, wie dieses Gesetz ausgearbeitet wird.
Ich frage mich vor allem auch, also ich meine, der ist ja nicht Teil der Bundesregierung
in dem Sinne, der Kulturbeauftragte ist ja, also als Kulturstaatsminister hat er ja keinen,
ist ja nicht wirklich Teil der Regierung, also ist ja kein Ministerium in dem Sinne.
Bin ich mal gespannt, über wen dann diese Initiative letzten Endes kommen soll.
Der Beauftragte der Bundesregierung für Kultur und Medien,
verträgt die Verantwortung für die Kultur- und Medienpolitik der Bundesrepublik Deutschland,
Aufgaben Also der kann natürlich ein Gesetzesvorhaben irgendwie vorbereiten,
aber ich glaube das muss dann Die wird dann von irgendeinem Ministerium eingebracht Ja.
Dann muss ja da noch irgendein Minister drüber befinden, da bin ich mal gespannt Wer das.
Das wird er schon hinkriegen aber okay, also Filmförderung machen die Förderung
der Literatur und Buchbranche, Denkmalpflege, Medienpolitik,
Schutz von Kultur gut, aber okay,
werden wir mal sehen, das wird auf jeden Fall ein Thema für uns werden,
wie die Erlöse der Medienstadt und wie ein Verleger der Medienstadt in Deutschland rettet,
Dann haben wir in den USA ja eine zunehmende Wahrnehmung und große Sorgen,
dass diese Trump-Regierung sich nicht mehr so beeindruckt zeigen wird von Richterinnen und Gesetzen.
Die haben ja eine Reihe sehr skurriler Dinge gemacht, im Prinzip im Kampf gegen
die Universität Harvard zum Beispiel.
Etwas, was wir hier nicht so ausführlich behandeln, was aber auch ein absolut irrer Vorgang ist.
Und in diesem Kontext streiten die sich jetzt vor Gericht,
dann gibt es irgendwelche Urteile im Sinne von Harvard, dann gibt es wieder
andere und irgendwie merkt man so, dass die Regierung sich zunehmend eigentlich
gar nicht mehr für die Gerichte interessiert und das auch relativ offen ausspricht.
Und das ist ja eine Entwicklung, die sehr bedenklich ist.
Und jetzt haben wir die gleiche Situation mit unserer neuen Bundesregierung.
Da gibt es ein Gerichtsverfahren. Wir haben gesehen, die Ankündigungen und auch
die Durchsetzung dieser Ankündigung, dass es stärkere Grenzkontrollen gibt.
Und dass bei diesen Grenzkontrollen die Vorgabe jetzt gilt, dass man Menschen,
die zum Zweck des Beantragens von Asyl dort einreisen, an der Grenze zurückweist.
Weil, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, man ja Asyl nur beantragen kann,
wenn man in diesem Land ist.
Und der Trick 17, den die Bundesrepublik dann anwendet, ist eben zu verhindern,
dass die Leute hierher kommen.
Und dann können die nämlich auch kein Asyl beantragen.
Und gleichzeitig meine ich,
dass Reisefreiheit innerhalb der Europäischen Union herrscht und dass sich ja
die europäischen Staaten ohnehin ein bisschen darüber zanken,
dass einige eben an den Außengrenzen der EU sind und damit im Zweifelsfall Staaten sind,
wo Flüchtende zuerst die EU betreten.
Und dass die EU sich dann überlegt, wie sie die denn weiter verteilt.
Und einige EU-Staaten an den Außengrenzen sagen eben, naja, fahr doch,
willst du nach Deutschland fahren? Alles klar, da lang. Tschüss, fahr.
Und jetzt sagen die Deutschen an der Grenze, du darfst hier nicht rein.
Du bist ja gar, wir möchten nicht, dass du hier reinkommst.
Und dann wurde mit Unterstützung der NGO Pro Asyl,
haben drei Asylsuchende aus Somalia vor dem Verwaltungsgericht Berlin gegen
ihre Zurückweisung an der deutsch-polnischen Grenze geklagt.
Die wollten von Polen nach Deutschland und dann standen da irgendwie und haben
gesagt, nee, du darfst hier nicht rein.
Und dann hat das Verwaltungsgericht Berlin gesagt, die Zurückweisung der Asylsuchenden
oder überhaupt von Asylsuchenden an einer EU-Binnengrenze ist europarechtswidrig.
Es gibt nämlich europarechtlich durchaus die Maßgabe, dass Deutschland die dann reinlassen muss.
Und insofern hat das Verwaltungsgericht, Verwaltungsgerichte sind jetzt keine
politischen Gerichte, die lesen halt, die gucken sich die Verwaltungsakte an
und sagen, gibt es da eine Rechtsgrundlage für oder nicht. Und dann haben die
gesagt, das geh bitte nicht hier.
Und die einzige Möglichkeit, wie man das temporär aussetzen kann,
auch das hatten wir hier glaube ich am Rande erwähnt, ist eben,
dass es eine Notlage gibt und das Verwaltungsgericht Berlin hat geguckt und
hat gesagt, wir können irgendwie eigentlich ehrlich gesagt keine Notlage feststellen.
Notlage in der Definition wäre ja so etwas wie ja, was weiß ich,
gibt gerade irgendeine Ausnahmesituation im Land oder so Und die CDU-spezifisch
Dobrindt sagen, bei uns ist die Notlage,
wir wollen keine Asylbewerber.
Notlage, zack, Grenzkontrolle. Und dann verlängern wir das.
Und dann haben die in drei Fällen verloren, wo gesagt wird, hier,
es besteht keine Notlage. Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt.
Und dann sagt der Dobrindt, ja, hier, das ist ja Verwaltungsgericht Berlin,
das ist eine Einzelfallentscheidung.
Und das Einzige, was wir müssen also hier einfach nur noch besser begründen.
Und deswegen können wir dieses Urteil jetzt ignorieren. Und ich halte quasi
meine Anweisung in Richtung der Bundespolizei aufrecht Zurückweisungen vorzunehmen.
Obwohl ja hier die Judikative festgestellt hat, dass die Grundlage,
die europarechtliche Grundlage dafür nicht besteht und ich damit gegen Europarecht verstoße.
Und er hat damit Rückendeckung von dem Bundeskanzler, der sagt, da ist Einzelfall.
Das ist natürlich lustig, Wenn man jetzt alles, was Grundsatzentscheidung ist,
einfach zur Einzelfallentscheidung erklärt und dann weiter...
Eben jeden Einzelfall vor Gericht verlieren will.
Und der Arne Semsrott mit seinem Namen, aber insgesamt die Organisation Frag den Staat,
haben jetzt eine Strafanzeige erstattet gegen den Bundesinnenminister,
weil er an der nicht rechtmäßigen Weisung festhält, Zurückweisungen durchzuführen.
Offener Rechtsbruch nennt das Arne. Und ich glaube, das kann man durchaus so sehen.
Wenn die Regierung vor Gericht verliert und dann sagt, ja, ist mir egal, das geht so nicht,
dann ist das glaube ich ein Problem und da kommt jetzt,
interessanterweise Arnes Buch auch zum Tragen, wir hatten ja ihn,
als er das Buch veröffentlicht hat bei uns zu Gast und haben da das wunderschöne Wort,
Remonstration gelernt Remonstration ist wenn,
Beamte sich einer nicht rechtmäßigen Weisung ihrer Vorgesetzten widersetzen müssen.
Und das hatte Arne ursprünglich in diesem Buch beschrieben, das Buch heißt ja,
Machtübernahme, was passiert, wenn Rechtsextremer in die Regierung kommen und
hat ja darin auch beschrieben, was man dann, so welche Möglichkeiten Menschen
im Rechtsstaat haben, wenn,
illegale Anordnungen stattfinden und jetzt haben sie eine Remonstrationsvorlage,
wo man quasi, wenn man angewiesen wird, eine Zurückweisung vorzunehmen an der Grenze,
sagen kann, hiermit remonstriere ich, weil das, was hier von mir verlangt wird, ist nicht rechtens.
Außerdem haben sie die Strafanzeige erstattet und ebenfalls eine Vorlage für
Strafanzeigen gegen Bundespolizistinnen,
die diese Zurückweisung durchführen.
Also dafür eine Vorlage bereitgestellt und eine Vorlage für Dienstaufsichtsbeschwerden.
Das heißt, nebenher haben wir hier auch noch im Prinzip eine Klitz...
Es ist jetzt noch keine Verfassungskrise, es ist ja nur ein Verwaltungsgericht,
aber auch die deutsche Bundesregierung setzt sich...
Das Gesetz stellt sich gegen das Gesetz und die Gerichte, die sie anwenden.
Das ist schon ein bemerkenswerter Fall, möchte ich sagen.
Ja, und das ist vor allem immer für den oft gefürchteten Moment so,
was ist, wenn die AfD mal irgendeine Regierungsverantwortung übernimmt.
Da stellt sich natürlich sofort die Frage, wie resilient ist eigentlich unser System?
Weil man ja auch in den USA gemerkt hat, jetzt mit Trump, viel ist einfach nur Konvention.
Und die Konvention leitet sich eigentlich eher aus so einer kulturellen Kontrolle ab.
Aber wenn sich die Kultur im Lande ändert, also wenn der Modus operandi,
den alle für angemessen halten, sich ändert, dann ändert sich auch das politische Verhalten.
Früher sind Politiker noch zurückgetreten wegen,
die haben mal eine Privatreise in irgendeinem Dienstwagen gemacht und das war dann der große Skandal,
über das Deutschland dann tagelang diskutiert hat und dann müssten halt sofort
die Minister zurücktreten,
weil sie irgendwo 500 Euro quasi sich ergaunert haben, könnte man sagen.
Mittlerweile sind wir halt auf dem Level, wo der amerikanische Präsident Krypto-Scams
ausgibt und sich irgendwie aus allen Ländern der Welt irgendwie über diese Krypto-Gelder
mit Millionen bestechen lässt und irgendwie nobody cares.
Also das ist so der Level und wenn man dann halt so, ja die Gerichte wollen
dann zurückhalten und so, ja ach Gerichte, was kümmern mich die Gerichte.
Ich muss kurz noch sagen, auf welchen Paragrafen des Strafrechts sich die Anzeige
gegen Dobrindt bezieht und zwar ist das der Paragraf 357 StGB Verleitung von
Untergebenen zu Straftaten.
Das wollte ich noch inhaltlich beitragen.
Ja, bin mal gespannt, wie das klappt, wie das läuft.
Ich bin wirklich gespannt, wie jetzt die Staatsanwaltschaft Berlin damit umgeht,
dass bei ihr der Bundesinnenminister angezeigt wurde.
Bin gespannt. Ich würde vermuten, die lassen sich irgendwas einfallen,
warum sie das lange liegen lassen und dann irgendwann einstellen.
Kann schon sein.
Okay.
Die USA haben sich auch was Nettes einfallen lassen.
Und zwar haben die, also.
Diese Nachricht ist gar nicht so viel behandelt worden, hatte ich den Eindruck.
Oder zumindest nicht in der Größe. und auf eine Weise zu Recht,
auf eine Weise zu Unrecht.
Also sie haben gesagt, hier diese ganzen Studenten- und Austauschschüler-Visa,
das tut uns leid, das kriegen wir irgendwie gerade gar nicht hin,
da kommen wir nicht mehr hinterher.
Und außerdem wollen wir jetzt mal mehr kontrollieren, was die denn so in den
sozialen Medien machen.
Und da ist die News,
wie im Moment die kontrollieren soziale Medien,
ist eigentlich keine, weil man die ja angeben, man ist gehalten,
seine Social Media Accounts anzugeben bei der Visa-Beantragung.
Also da gibt es dann so ein Feld und dann soll man seine Social Media Accounts angeben.
Und jetzt sagen sie, ja, wir müssen mal gucken, wer hier so kommt und wir müssen
eigentlich vor allem mal schauen, wie die sich in dieser ganzen Gaza-Geschichte
in den sozialen Medien verhalten.
Weil nicht, dass wir hier irgendwie Terroristen ins Land holen.
Finde ich ziemlich krass. Also das ist das Land, dessen Vizepräsident auf die
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz gekommen ist und einen von der Meinungsfreiheit erzählt hat.
Das ist dieses Land.
Und es ist auch das Land, in dem alle diese sozialen Netzwerke beheimatet sind.
Und das war zu einem Zeitpunkt, als Donald Trump und Elon Musk noch Best Friends Forever waren.
Was ja dann auch heißt, wenn du jetzt sagst, okay, in die USA einreisen,
muss ich mal kurz meine Tweets und LinkedIn-Posts zum Thema Gaza filtern und
noch mal vielleicht ein paar löschen,
bevor da nachher irgendwie so eine Immigration-Person sieht,
dass ich Meinungen vertrete,
die hier nicht einreisegefährdend sind.
Und das ist ja glaube ich, so wird es nämlich nicht sein.
Ich meine, ich würde davon ausgehen, dass die US-Regierung einen privilegierten
Zugang zu diesen Plattformen hat.
Und dass du jetzt nicht sagst, ich lösche mal noch eben irgendwie zwei,
drei Tweets und dann geht das schon mit der Einreise oder mit dem Visum oder mit dem ESTA.
Das wird nämlich nicht so sein. Ich glaube schon, dass sie da einen etwas besseren
Zugang haben Und dass dann nicht jemand durch deine Tweets scrollt bei der Einreisebehörde.
Ich glaube, die liegen alle schon ausgedruckt vor, zu dem Zeitpunkt,
wo du landest, weil das wahrscheinlich auch alles vorher angegeben werden muss.
Das Feld war bisher immer, also da stand nicht dran, dass man da was eintragen muss.
Ich habe da immer mein LinkedIn angegeben, weil ich mich da zurückhalte.
Wirklich.
LinkedIn schon.
Ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall krass. Ich meine, was J.D.
Vance und die Meinungsfreiheit betrifft, was er ja meinte, ist ja nicht deine
Meinung, sondern seine Meinung.
Ja, klar.
Ich finde das sehr interessant.
Es ist eine sehr perfide Möglichkeit, natürlich auch einen potenziell sehr starken,
Einfluss auf das Social-Media-Verhalten vieler Menschen zu nehmen.
Wenn du sagst, übrigens, folgende Themen sehen wir so und so und Und wenn du
hier irgendwie nochmal in dieses tolle Land möchtest, dann sei gewiss,
dass wir uns das anschauen.
Insbesondere wenn du hier irgendwie so ein Studentenvisum haben willst oder so.
Stell dir mal vor, früher haben Leute gesagt, ja in den sozialen Medien musst du schon aufpassen.
Weil in 20 Jahren können die Leute dann immer noch deine Bilder sehen,
wie du da mit dem Bier oder so.
Und jetzt ist es so, mit den sozialen Medien musst du schon aufpassen,
sonst kannst du eventuell nicht mehr in die USA einreisen.
Und hier sind übrigens die politischen Einstellungen, die in den USA gerade gelten oder nicht.
Und vielleicht passt du mal auf mit dem Fenster und wie weit du dich da rauslehnst.
Das ist schon echt eine Ansage.
Ja
Man ist halt im Prinzip das Diktatoren Playbook, in der Türkei beobachten wir
das ja nun schon länger und ja, würde mich auch nicht wundern,
wenn das in Ungarn dann irgendwie auch bald losgeht,
Bedenklich Nur.
Dass die halt, also ja, also dass diese Unternehmen halt in diesem Land sind.
Das ist schon nochmal eine ganze Nummer härter.
Also die werden, wenn sie was finden wollen in den sozialen Medien,
keine Schwierigkeiten haben.
Ja, das ist natürlich richtig.
Während, weiß nicht, wenn jetzt irgendwie die Türkei sagt, hier das und das
und das ist uns nicht genehm, da würde es halt eventuell mit der Nummer durchkommen,
wenn es Feuer löscht, weil sie keine privilegierten Zugänge...
Ja, aber vielleicht, ich meine, die werden auch ihre Feier aus am Laufen haben
und das alles schon archiviert haben, Also das ist auch keine Garantie.
Was einmal öffentlich ist, davon muss man ausgehen. Irgendjemand wird das vielleicht
schon mitgeschrieben haben.
Also ich habe ja die USA unter Trump immer boykottiert.
Zumindest was meine Reisetätigkeiten anging.
Jetzt einmal kurz die USA unter Biden besucht. Das war sehr nett.
Und ich habe viele interessante Länder kennengelernt.
Indem ich einfach nicht in die USA gereist bin. Kann ich nur empfehlen.
Und als jemand, hier fanden unsere jüngeren Hörerinnen und Hörer,
als jemand, der ein Jahr in den USA zur Schule gegangen ist, würde ich,
empfehlen, das in einem anderen Land zu machen.
Das war in Ordnung, aber würde ich die Entscheidung nochmal treffen,
würde ich in ein anderes Land gehen.
Um noch mehr kulturelle Vielfalt, Also sagen wir, um kulturelle Vielfalt auch
als Bereicherung wahrnehmen zu können.
Weil das, was in den USA an kultureller Vielfalt wahrnimmst,
das ist im Zweifelsfall keine Bereicherung.
Welches Land würdest du denn jetzt nehmen?
Puh, schwierig. Ich bin ja seit längerem mit der Schule fertig.
Merkt man gar nicht.
Sodass ich,
ich habe heute einen Menschen gesehen der hatte ein T-Shirt an,
und auf diesem T-Shirt stand ich gendere nicht, ich habe einen Schulabschluss,
und da habe ich mir echt wirklich gedacht, das T-Shirt ist so entlarvend weil ich mir so dachte genau,
du hast einen Schulabschluss.
Und wenn das ein Abitur wäre, stünde da Abitur. Und wenn du studiert hättest,
stünde da ein Studium oder ein Diplom oder ein Bachelor oder sowas.
Aber da steht eben Schulabschluss.
Das fand ich sehr entlarven, dieses Shirt. Konnte ich mich sehr lange drüber abwenden.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, was das miteinander zu tun hat.
Natürlich, das hat überhaupt nichts miteinander zu tun. Das ist einfach ein Idiot.
Aber es ist Wahnsinn, dass Menschen, also ich gebe zu, ich weiche gerade ein bisschen vom Thema ab.
Ein bisschen, ja.
Ich fand es auf jeden Fall faszinierend, dass es für Menschen so wichtig ist,
dass sie sogar noch mal sagen, ich habe Schule abgeschlossen.
Okay, bleib mal beim Thema. Wo würdest du denn jetzt zur Schule gehen wollen,
wenn du die Wahl hättest?
Ich würde mir ein Land suchen, das, also in dem es Demokratie, gibt.
Aussicht darauf, dass die noch ein paar Jahre hält.
Okay, das schrägt ja schon mal die Liste stark ein.
Und ich würde mir, glaube ich, vielleicht doch etwas, also Kulturschock hast
du eh und dann kannst du auch sagen, du machst, weiß ich nicht,
Südafrika, Neuseeland oder was weiß ich, ja,
Kanada,
Nicaragua, weiß der Geier. auf jeden Fall.
Nicaragua?
Die Bildung selber ist dir eigentlich egal, dir geht es jetzt nur ums Land.
Als hätte ich jetzt besonders gute Bildung in dem einen Jahr in den USA genossen.
Als hätte mich das jetzt dann zum Intellektuellen gemacht.
Ja gut, aber du bist ja vielleicht da hingefahren mit der Erwartung,
dass du da eine gute Ausbildung genießt.
Genau Tim. Als ich als Teenager mir aussuchen konnte, in welchem Land ich ein
Jahr lebe, war mein Primärinteresse, dass ich da eine besonders hohe Bildung
genieße und zu einer möglichst guten Schule gehe.
Was war denn deine Primärmotivation?
Meine Erwartung war natürlich, dass es in den USA besser ist.
Das war ja immer im Fernsehen, dass es da besser ist.
Du meinst alles besser.
Night Rider.
Mehr Zukunft und so, ja. Okay, ich verstehe schon. Wurde es eigentlich nur an den Strand.
Das könnt ihr euch eh von der Backe putzen, weil diese ganzen Austauschschülerinnen
und Schüler primär im Landesinneren,
in den Flyover States landen, weil dort erstens Menschen das einerseits machen,
weil sie ein bisschen Geld für kriegen und andererseits, weil sie angehalten
werden von ihren Kirchen,
da missionarisch tätig zu sein.
Also du bist im Zweifelsfall irgendwo, was weiß ich, Kansas,
Ohio, Oklahoma, so irgendwo da.
Aber wenn du meinst, du gehst jetzt irgendwo hin und sagst, hallo,
ich wollte einmal Austausch, ja, in Amerika machen und du denkst,
du landest dann irgendwie in Florida in Strandnähe oder so, das ist unwahrscheinlich.
Und in New York haben die Leute viel zu kleine Wohnungen, um da irgendjemanden,
das heißt, da kommst du auch nicht hin. Es sei denn, du zahlst extra.
Deswegen,
Na gut, Hongkong, weiß ich nicht, je nachdem. Vielleicht für ein Highschool-Jahr reicht es noch.
Tokyo?
Also Japan wäre auf jeden Fall, glaube ich, eine Option. Irgendwas Spannendes.
Ja, ich meine, eigentlich ist ja jedes Land interessant, weil alles,
was anders ist als Deutschland, kann ja zwangsläufig nur interessant sein.
Die Frage ist nur, wie sehr anders soll es sein und wie sehr anders soll die Sprache sein?
Naja, musst du selber entscheiden. Falls ihr dann auch drüber nachdenkt.
Wenn ihr Lust habt, im mittleren Westen mit den Republikanern zur Kirche zu
gehen, macht ihr Highschool ja in den USA.
Kann euch keiner nehmen. Unter Trump, das wird spitze.
Wahnsinn.
Na gut. Hatten wir nicht noch Themen?
Ja, auch Themen.
Es gibt die BWI GmbH.
Das ist die, eine Bundesgesellschaft, Bundeswehr IT oder sowas.
Und die stellt quasi IT für die Bundeswehr bereit.
Und die Bundeswehr braucht ja Internet und auch irgendwas im Internet.
Und was macht man im Internet? Also wenn man im Internet sein will,
dann muss man eine Cloud. Brauchst eine Cloud.
Und ja.
Hast du auch eine Cloud? Ich habe eigenes Server.
Das ist von früher. Ich bin ja old school. Heute klickst du dir AWS oder sowas.
Das ist ja dann deine eigene Cloud. Du hast dein eigenes Bölkchen.
Ich habe meinen eigenen Container. Bei Google habe ich meinen eigenen Container.
Ja, ist so. Wäre jetzt heute so, wenn so ein Gen Z sagen würde,
Ich möchte auch im Internet sein,
Also im richtigen Internet nicht nur Instagram und TikTok.
Dann würde sich wahrscheinlich eine Workload in irgendeinem Azure, GCP oder AWS hosten.
Und die Bundeswehr sagt jetzt, ja wir wollen auch, wir brauchen auch,
aber wir wollen eine eigene Cloud. Und die kaufen jetzt, also die haben einen
Vertrag unterzeichnet, über die Google Cloud Airgap.
Und damit machen sie die Private Cloud der Bundeswehr. Das ist die P-Cloud BW.
Und die wird Google Airgap gehostet.
Das habe ich auch versucht zu verstehen. Da gibt es eine Pressemitteilung von
Google und das ist die Google Cloud Airgap.
Die Google Cloud Airgap ist eine souveräne Lösung des Herstellers Google Cloud.
Und damit, dann kann die BWI, kann also dann Google Cloud, also GCP,
für die Bundeswehr in den eigenen Rechenzentren physisch vollständig von anderen
Google-Systemen oder Netzwerken isoliert, Klammer auf, ergebt,
installieren und betreiben.
Und damit hat die Bundeswehr zu jeder Zeit die Kontrolle über die eigenen Daten
und kommt damit ihrer Anforderung nach Informations- und Datensicherheit nach.
Das klingt ein bisschen so, als würden die irgendwie quasi ihren wirklichen
Core von GCP lizenzieren lassen.
Und dann hast du halt wahrscheinlich die APIs, die dir Google sonst auch geben würde.
Aber es ist alles AirGap. Ich verstehe nicht, warum die Air,
also eine AirGap Cloud macht für mich sehr wenig Sinn.
Also in der im wirklichen eigentlichen Sinne des Wortes ergibt.
Das ist ja eher Standalone, würde ich das nennen.
Oder, nee, weißt du, was das ist? Das ist eine On-Prem-Cloud.
Das ist eine On-Prem-Cloud, ist das?
Das musst du jetzt mal erklären. Also On-Prem, damit meinst du On-Premises,
also auf dem eigenen Gelände.
Ja, also wenn ich es richtig verstehe, sie holen sich zwar die Technik von Google
und das Management, aber machen das auf die eigenen Infrastruktur.
Ist ja auch erstmal okay.
On-Prem ist auch ein Hosting-Begriff. Nicht unbedingt, dass der jetzt bei dir
steht, der Server, aber dass du überhaupt einen eigenen Server hast.
Der kann in den eigenen Räumlichkeiten sein, aber es kann auch beispielsweise,
wenn du den jetzt im Datencenter hast, würdest du immer noch sagen, das hosten wir On-Prem.
Aber das Entscheidende ist, du hast einen Server.
Und eine On-Prem-Cloud, ich finde die besonders On-Prem-Cloud nennen,
ich werde denen mal eine E-Mail schreiben. Aber die Google Cloud eher gibt.
Ansonsten ist das alles nur voll mit Buzzwords. Und ich denke, wir sehen hier,
können hier Zeuge sein, wie die Bundeswehr sich so richtig in die eigene digitale
Souveränität begibt, indem sie auf einen Cloud-Stack von Google setzt,
den sie dann auch noch selber hosten muss.
Also das ist das ist der Souveränitätsniveau, was wir in Deutschland heute noch erreichen können.
Wenn wir schon sagen, wir wollen es aber nicht bei Google, da müssen wir immer
noch deren Stack nehmen.
Und brauchen zur Hilfe SAP. Die Frauen sind auch noch dabei.
Ja, also ich finde das jetzt nicht so schlimm, muss ich sagen.
Es wäre, Tim, der schöne, also die hätten das mit Gaia X machen sollen.
Ja. Du lachst.
Die wollen ja auch, dass es funktioniert.
Und das ist doch genau, das ist doch die Meldung hier.
Selbst wenn du, selbst in den kritischen Bereichen, wo du sagst, du willst,
du würdest wirklich auch einen extra Weg gehen, um wirklich zu sagen,
nee, nee, nee, komm, wir können uns hier keinerlei Abhängigkeiten leisten. Das ist unser Militär.
Das ist schlimm. Also hier können wir nun wirklich nicht von Huawei das nehmen.
Hier können wir jetzt echt, hier müssen wir mal richtig selber,
da könntest du jetzt sagen, du nimmst hier Kubernetes oder, also du könntest ja.
Du hast ja sogar noch die 100 Milliarden Budget.
Ja, aber ich meine, im Prinzip leistet dieses Produkt das ja auch.
Wenn ich das richtig verstehe, ist das halt eine komplette private Cloud-Lösung
von Google, aber die nicht von Google betrieben wird, sondern von der Bundeswehr
in dem Fall dann halt auch selbst betrieben wird.
Und ja, man kann da, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, basiert das ja letzten Endes
irgendwo auch auf diesen Technologien und das ist halt eine Cloud-Lösung,
also sozusagen auch ein Rechenzentrum, was nicht mit dem Internet verbunden ist.
Also das macht schon irgendwie Sinn.
Das ist mit dem Internet verbunden. Das ist nur, das ist ja,
also natürlich ist das mit dem Internet verbunden. Das ist nicht Airgap.
Das ist ja der Gag, das hat mit Airgap überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Die nennen das nur ergibt, weil der zu Google ergibt ist. Also was willst du
mit einer Cloud oder Internet?
Ich weiß nicht, so über,
eigene Protokolle einsteigen, mit einem Modem einwählen.
Ist ja auch dann schon nicht mehr ergibt.
Ja, okay.
Die haben,
ja, sie machen es jetzt, ich wollte nur sagen,
selbst wenn du 100 Milliarden hast und Zeitenwende ist und so weiter,
schaffst du nicht mehr eine moderne Cloud-Infrastruktur offenbar mit dem höchsten
Ziel der Souveränität selber zu betreiben mit europäischen Mitteln.
Und das ist schon ein schockierendes eine schockierende Erkenntnis.
Nö. Ich finde es gut, dass sie überhaupt mal ihre Infrastruktur voranbringen.
Ja, das ist ja, das ist aber nicht die Meldung, Tim. Okay, wir machen die nächste. Pornoseite.
Genau, mach mal lieber was mit Porno hier.
Mach mal was, was auf gar keinen Fall ergibt ist.
Es gibt, warte mal, wie heißen die? Die habe ich jetzt nicht mitnotiert.
Doch, die heißen X-Videos und Co. Muss ich nochmal gucken.
X-Videos, Pornhub X-Videos und noch eine.
Das willst du jetzt gucken?
Nee, das ist bei mir ergabt. Bei mir ist das ergabt.
Oder haust ich das on-prem? Ich bin jetzt nicht mehr sicher.
Also, die haben, es gibt hier so unterschiedliche Seiten, die sind nur für Erwachsene,
ich kenne die alle gar nicht und die werden jetzt,
Da beklagt sich die EU-Kommission, dass sie keine angemessenen und verhältnismäßigen
Maßnahmen ergreifen, um einen Altersnachweis, eine wirksame Altersverifikation durchzuführen.
Auf diesen Seiten ist es irgendwie so, dass sie draufkriegen,
hier darf man nur rein, wenn man 18 ist, dann gibt es einen großen Knopf,
ich bin 18, über 18, und dann darf man die Seite gucken.
Und da sagen die, nee, da sagt die EU, nee, du musst jetzt wirklich mal richtig gucken.
Beispielsweise Personalausweis zeigen lassen. Wir haben das hier schon öfter besprochen,
dass die meisten Leute wahrscheinlich, auch wenn sie sagen im Internet,
ist mir völlig egal, die können alle meine Daten haben, aber wenn ihr an der
Pornoseite ihren Ausweis zeigen müsst, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass der ein oder andere.
Abbruch erfolgen könnte. In dem Moment.
Könnt ihr mir vorstellen. Ich bin da aber auch gar nicht in dem Thema.
Und jetzt außerdem sagen sie, die hätten keine ausreichenden,
Risikobewertungen vorgelegt, das müssen ja große Plattformen machen,
um die negativen Auswirkungen auf Kinderrechte und das geistige sowie körperliche
Wohlbefinden der Nutzer zu identifizieren und zu mindern.
Deswegen kriegen die also jetzt Ärger nach dem Digital Services Act.
Und interessant ist, dass sie bei der Gelegenheit sagen, übrigens,
wir haben ja da eine technische Lösung, Wir machen jetzt die White-Label-Altersverifikations-App,
die wird im Sommer 2025 verfügbar sein,
die basiert auf derselben Technologie für die Ende 26 geplante European Digital
Wallet und da gibt es dann eine datenschutzkonforme Altersverifikation,
ohne weitere Identitätsinformationen preiszugeben.
Kann mir nicht vorstellen. Oder ich bin mal gespannt, wie sie das bauen.
Ich habe mir die Architektur noch nicht angeschaut. Ich weiß nicht,
ob sie schon veröffentlicht ist. Aber das wird auf jeden Fall lustig.
Jedenfalls zu dem European Identity Wallet.
Da waren ja jetzt schon die Leute, dass eben massives Tracking stattfinden kann,
weil die Brieftasche irgendwo zentral ist und dann quasi vorgewiesen wird.
Wir schauen uns das mal an. es wird auf jeden Fall unterhaltsam bleiben.
Das könnte auch so ein Kräftemessen werden, so ein Trump-Musk-artiges Kräftemessen,
wenn die EU jetzt irgendwie den Zugang zu diesen Seiten sperrt.
Oder erschwert. Da könnten sie ihr Wallet in große Gefahr mitbegeben,
wenn die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer mit den mit der Experience nicht happy sind.
Stellt sich wieder mal die Frage, was hat die EU jemals für uns getan?
Jetzt haben sie uns die Pornoseiten weggenommen.
Aber was haben die drüber sonst noch für uns gemacht?
Ach ja.
Dann hat der Kantorkel, der auch schon öfter bei uns in der Sendung zu Gast
war, mal wieder eine Meldung gemacht bei einem Unternehmen für Mitarbeiter-Benefits.
Heißt, diese Plattform heißt Corplife, also Corporate Life,
schöner Name, und da gibt's dann irgendwie einen Marktplatz mit über irgendwelchen Marken,
regionale, internationale Marken, die du dann irgendwie günstiger kaufen kannst,
gibt's irgendwelche Rabattdinger und der Zugang zu dieser Plattform ist eben
dann ein Corporate Benefit.
Und Essenszuschüsse oder sowas und Unternehmen wie Siemens, Microsoft und so nutzen das,
und das Unternehmen bezeichnet sich als Marktführerin in Österreich und dann
nach Deutschland exportiert.
Und da gab es dann 7800 PK-Pass-Dateien, das sind glaube ich die Wallet,
die Apple-Wallet-Dinger,
CSV-Dateien mit 145.000 Namen, E-Mail-Adressen und Unternehmenszugehörigkeiten,
Quellcode, Datenbank-Backup,
7 GB große Datenbank-Dump wegen Directory-Listings abrufbar.
Klassischer Fehler, du hast einen Ordner, für den Ordner hast du Directory-Listing,
das heißt, wenn du darauf zugreifst und der Web-Server nicht eine Index-HTML
findet, sagt er, pass auf, ich rendere einfach eine Webseite und liste die Dateien.
Und wenn dann da deine SQL-Backups liegen, dann weiß man, wo man sie zugreifen muss.
Wie früher.
Ja, und in Teilen lässt sich das über einen archivierten Link sogar nachvollziehen.
Ja, Meldung und fertig. Pick-up-Pass sind ja Apple Wallet und das sind also die Wallet-Files.
Ja, wir haben inzwischen Unmengen an Meldungen auch unter Disclosure liegen.
Wir kommen gerade kaum hinterher, die alle abzuarbeiten.
Und ja, Kantorkel hat auch nochmal gesagt, so viele der von uns gemeldeten Lücken
sind erschreckend banal.
Daten sind gleich offen zugänglich oder es genügt, eine ID hochzuzählen.
Wir würden uns mehr technische Herausforderungen wünschen.
Und tatsächlich, da es immer so triviale Themen sind und weil wir jetzt sehr,
sehr viele derartige Meldungen bekommen,
würde ich euch teilweise dann auch gerade zu dieser Zeit eventuell bitten,
zu überlegen, ob ihr es nicht vielleicht doch selber meldet.
Gerade wenn es wirklich nur Datenlecks sind,
wo die Gefahr, dass irgendwie der Hacker-Paragraf zur Anwendung kommt,
weil man von einem wirksamen Zugriffsschutz sprechen könnte,
dann auch wirklich sehr gering ist.
Denk doch mal einer an die Hacker. Immer diese total einfachen Sachen.
Naja, aber für die Junghackerinnen und Junghacker ist das ja auch schön,
wenn man da mal ein bisschen wenn man einfach mal anfängt jede ID,
die man so 5.480 ist einfach mal 5.479.
Internet Jugendhaft, aber man braucht ein bisschen Herausforderung Dann haben.
Wir noch einen Todesfall.
Zu vermelden.
Und zwar von John Young. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass der schon so alt war.
Der ist Ende 80 gewesen jetzt.
Baujahr 35.
Er hat die Webseite Cryptome betrieben.
Cryptome.org Auch immer noch im guten alten Stil.
Klassisches HTML 1.0.
Und der hat einfach immer fleißig geleakt jeden Monat des Jahres oder viele
Monate des Jahres immer irgendwelche Dateien,
Wildeste Kontexte, häufig, also viele davon bei weitem nicht so groß beachtet,
wie sie inhaltlich beachtet gehört hätten,
hat viel über die Julian Assange Anhörung und Verteidigung und Fälle veröffentlicht.
Ich glaube, die beiden standen nicht auf dem besten Fuße, wenn ich das gut in Erinnerung habe.
Ja, John Young hat tatsächlich mal wikileaks.org registriert die Domänen,
also ganz am Anfang waren sie da sozusagen im selben Boot, aber er hat sich
dann wohl mit Assange relativ früh zerstritten,
über irgendwelche Spendengelder und hat sich dann relativ scharf von wikileaks dann abgegrenzt.
Also er gehört halt zu diesen Cypherpunks, zu diesen frühen Leuten,
die halt da für Online-Rechte,
demonstriert haben, so John Gilmore, Philipp Zimmermann, der PGB-Mensch und so weiter.
Ja, aber er ist immer so ein bisschen der Einzelkämpfer gewesen mit Cryptome
und Cryptome war quasi so das, was Wikileaks immer sein wollte.
Einfach nur so ein Archiv, wo Informationen zu finden sind und interessanterweise
ist er nie so wirklich ins Rampenlicht groß geraten.
Also er hat halt auch keine Attitüde an den Tag gelegt, sag ich mal.
Als Person selten irgendwie aufgetreten und sichtbar gewesen,
sondern es gab einfach immer nur diese Webseite und da war halt immer Zeug drauf.
Aber jetzt ist das lange Leben dann zum Ende gekommen.
Seit 1997 hat er das gemacht oder 96?
Ja, 94. Ja, sechslingslos.
Schade, aber irgendwann ist es halt vorbei. Wie diese Sendung.
Ja.
War auch wieder lange, aber das war es.
War gar nicht so lang. Eine Stunde oder so.
Nur eine Stunde.
Du musst ja ganz viel rausschneiden wieder.
Ja, es ist halt Sommer. Man merkt auch,
hier in Deutschland muss erstmal der ganze Politapparat sich erstmal hochfahren
und das war noch nicht so weit und das ist alles auch sehr von Außenpolitik
dominiert, habe ich so den Eindruck derzeit.
Ach stimmt, der März war ja bei Trump und wurde nicht komplett verarscht.
Ne, der hat es, muss man sagen, vielleicht hat er auch nur ein bisschen Glück
gehabt, aber er hat es auch klug angestellt, muss man sagen.
Also er hat es geschafft, da so eine Trump-kompatible Schmeichelei an den Tag
zu legen, ohne sich komplett zum Horst zu machen.
Und ist offensichtlich gut beraten gewesen.
Ich habe nur die Situation da gesehen, wo der,
die haben sich ja am D-Day getroffen,
also einen Tag vor dem D-Day, also das war der Beginn des Einstiegs der USA
in den zweiten Weltkrieg am Lande.
Dann sind sie in der Normandie-Küste in Frankreich eingefallen mit einer,
also auch eine super krasse militärische Operation mit diesen eigens dafür gebauten
Booten, um da schnell einen Hafen zu bauen und das ist sehr beeindruckend.
Ich war da vor vielen Jahren mal in dem Museum und damit begann dann die Niederlage,
Deutschlands und das Rückdrängen und dann,
bezieht der Merz sich darauf, dass es eben jetzt D-Day ist und dann sagt der
Trump, ja, daran denkt er natürlich nicht gerne zurück und wie kannst du so,
das ist so, also wenn du noch nicht mal das weißt,
Dass die USA dafür gesorgt haben, dass die Deutschen das als Befreiung verstanden
haben und nicht irgendwie rumrennen und sagen, oh, das ist aber schade,
dass wir den Zweiten Weltkrieg verloren haben.
Ja, ich meine, es ist halt auch die Gleichsetzung.
Aber das hat der Merz denen ja dann ganz gut erklärt.
Ja, das hat er dann gut erklärt.
Hat er kindgerecht erklärt.
Das ist aber auch, finde ich, auch generell einfach so eine simplistische Sicht
auf Deutschland und generell das Phänomen Faschismus.
Ich meine, da muss man den USA in gewisser Hinsicht jetzt auch dankbar sein,
weil ich glaube, die Debatte, dass Faschismus in sich eine deutsche Angelegenheit
ist, das ist jetzt dann auch langsam mal durch.
Also Faschismus ist eine Krankheit, die kann halt jedem passieren und wir sehen
halt auch immer mehr Länder,
die davon befallen werden und ja,
natürlich war die Niederlage im Zweiten Weltkrieg war halt die Befreiung Deutschlands
und andere Länder gehören da auch genauso befreit.
Und wie bald das passieren wird, werden wir sehen.
Ich meine, man sieht ja, was das für ein Menschenfraß in Russland ist und in
vielen anderen Ländern halt auch.
Und es ist für viele offensichtlich immer noch irgendwie erstrebenswert,
diese Methoden anzuwenden, auch wenn sie halt tief menschenverachtend sind und
von daher einfach auch abgestellt gehören.
Aber Herr Merz hat sich da in der Tat ganz gut geschlagen. Puh,
wenn sie gesagt haben, als sie da wieder rausmarschiert sind aus dem weißen
Haus. Aber hast du das gesehen?
Pfeffig, er hat ja so eine Geburtsurkunde mitgebracht von Trumps Großvater,
der ja aus Deutschland stammt.
Das ist schon ein guter Move. Ist Scholz nicht drauf gekommen.
Hätte ich auch weggelegt. Ja, hat er gut gemacht, super. Also bitte mehr davon.
Kann natürlich auch einfach sein, dass der Trump eigentlich im Gedanken schon bei Elon Musk war.
Who knows?
Dazu ist er dann von Fox News befragt worden. Der März.
Und war auch da. Klug und hat einfach gesagt, ist nicht unsere Angelegenheit,
kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Kenn ich mich nicht mehr aus.
Ja. Nun denn, Leute, das war's. Viel Spaß.
Bis nächstes Mal.
Bis bald. Tschüss.
Ciao, ciao.